[موسيقى]
يوم عادي استقلت فيه طالبه هنديه حافله
ركاب برفقه صديقها كان يظنني ان الحافله
ستقلهما الى وجهتهما بسلام لكن تلك الرحله
تحولت الى ابشع حادثه اغتصاب جماعي في
تاريخ الهند
الاسم جريمه فتاه الحافله التهمه الاغتصاب
والقتل المكان دلهي الهند الحكم الاعدام
في مساء السادس عشر من ديسمبر عام 2012
استقلت طالبه العلاج الطبيعي جيوتي سينغ
وصديقها
حافله في طريق عودتهما من السينما الى
المنزل
بطبيعه الحال كان يظنان ان كل شيء على ما
يرام ولم يعلما انه كان بانتظارهما في تلك
الحافله سته وحوش بشريه تتربص بهما
فبالاضافه الى السائق كان هناك خمسه شبان
على متن الحافله بينهم فتى في سن السابعه
عشره
تواطؤوا جميعا لاغتياد جيوطي وصديقها في
رحله من الرب
تعرض للضرب المبرح من قبل الشبان السته
اما جيوتي فتعرضت للاغتصاب والتعذيب
الوحشي دون اي رحمه او شفقه
على قارعه الطريق في مدينه دلهي تخلص
المعتدون من الضحيتين المدرجتين بدمائهما
الاعتداء تسبب لجيوتي بجروح بالغه ونزيف
داخلي جراء تعذيبها بقضبان حديديه وبعد
معاناه استمرت 13 يوما في مستشفى نقلت
اليه بسنغافوره توفيت متاثره بجروحها
احتاجت الشرطه الى سته ايام للقبض على
مرتكبي الجريمه فيما عم الغضب انحاء
البلاد وخرجت تظاهرات مليونيه واحتجاجات
على اخفاق الدوله بمعالجه العنف الجنسي ضد
المراه حيث اظهرت احصاءات رسميه تسجيل
اكثر من 24 الف حاله اغتصاب في نفس العام
الذي قتلت فيه جيوتي الامر الذي اجبر
الحكومه على تغليظ الاحكام بحق المغتصبين
[موسيقى]
وفي منه
استغرقت محاكمه المعتدين نحو ثمان سنوات
وفي عام 2020 جرى اعدام اربعه من السته
شنقا اذ سبق ان عثر على احدهم منتحرا في
سجنه عام 2013 اما المتهم السادس فكان
يبلغ من العمر 17 عاما في ذلك الوقت واطلق
سراحه عام 2015 بعد ان قضى ثلاث سنوات في
مرفق للاصلاح وهو الحد الاقصى للعقوبه
للاحداث في الهند
جيوتي تحولت الى ايقونه في بلادها لتسليط
الضوء على حوادث الاغتصاب والعنف الجنسي
التي تعانيها عشرات الاف النساء في الهند
سنويا والمطالبه بانزال اشد العقوبات بحق
المعتدين
[موسيقى]